je ne sais pas comment commencer cette
vidéo
comme toujours c'est une avalanche
d'informations et en même temps tout est
absolument flou mais bon je pense
sincèrement que ça va commencer à se
terminer je vous invite tout d'abord à
voir la vidéo précédente pour être à
jour concernant tout ce qu'il ya à
savoir sur la série et c est ce que j'en
pense puis évidemment je le calme
maintenant comme ça c'est fait on est
débarrassé vous êtes nombreux à regarder
la chaîne sans être abonnée aux vidéos
donc n'hésitez pas à le faire
voilà tout d'abord c'est un bel hommage
à malcolm et surtout le fait que les
enfants parle face caméra comme le fait
malcolm sur sa série donc ça démontre
bien voilà l'importance des enfants je
trouve
c'était une petite pensée comme ça que
j'avais envie de balancer mais voilà je
ne vais pas faire de la région
d'épisodes ce n'est pas trop mon rôle
mais j'aimerais vous balancer du mystère
de la théorie et c'est ce que j'ai en
tête
j'ai besoin de parler daguenet ce car
son cas est vraiment particulier et on
voit tout et son contraire sur le net la
possibilité d'une agatha harkness à ces
cartes à moitié de plus en plus mais ne
diminue pas l'importance daguenet ce au
contraire
son identité est difficile à deviner et
c'est un contraste énorme avec ce que
nous propose la série k rwanda vision
nous caresse dans le sens du poil
même si tout est flou il y a de la
référence à foison je me rappelle pas
avoir déjà vu autant de rêves aux comics
dans le mc eu les costumes sont même de
mise pourtant haguenets ce n'est pas
identifiée par le sword
elle parlait à oujda d'être enceinte
dans l'épisode 2 elle est toujours là
précis pour aider au rwanda et là c'est
le carnaval dans cet épisode 6
[Rires]
contrairement à tous les autres
habitants à gonesse est la seule à ne
pas être réellement bloqués elle répond
à vision et ensuite
mais qu'est ce qu'elle fout ici en fait
elle est la voisine de wendat et vision
et ce n'est pas comme si tu te faisais
des amis à west view tout est sous
l'influencé de ouandda elle n'a aucune
raison d'être au niveau de la bordure de
la ville et puis là où ça m'a encore
plus perturbée c'est que cette dernière
qui est à moitié dans le mal avant de se
faire réveiller par vision est toute
joyeuse après que vision les remis dans
son état secondaire en employant des
termes qu'elle disait dans les épisodes
précédents donc d'autres époques et ce
qu'elle ne jouerait pas un rôle il n'y a
pas forcément de réponses derrière tout
ça mais à guinness est une actrice
principale du problème et au vu de ses
actes
tout au long des épisodes précédents et
cetera on peut suspecter un méphisto
derrière tout ça oui je suis toujours
autant partisans de la présence de
méphisto et j'ai envie d'aller encore
plus loin concernant hague nes et
méphisto justin haguenets sait se
montrer comme une excellente voisine et
monica rambo parle d'un contact dans
west view est ce que ce ne serait pas
agyness dans l'idée agnèse a pu
sympathiser avec monica quand elle était
présente en tant que géraldine jouant un
rôle de fausses voisine de fausses
hypnotisé agyness aurait pu rassurer
monica pour faire genre
elle est une taupe dans west view de
quoi lui tendre un piège quand elle
reviendra dans la ville et on peut
enchaîner avec pietro déjà dans son
comportement et son vocabulaire
pietro est très douteux et je vois deux
cas de figure pour ce dernier deux par
sa condition et le moment de faiblesse
de wendat qui a révélé à quoi il
ressemblait vraiment sans oublier les
révélations faites sur vision pietro est
bel et bien mort il semblerait que l'on
soit face à son cadavre maquiller dans
l'illusion
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec vision
déjà dans ce premier cas de figure
pietro serait revenu d'entre les morts
envoyé par méphisto pourquoi suite à
l'appel de wendat enfin appels entre
guillemets parce que ça peut être une
illusion de méphisto pietro aurait pu
marchander son âme avec le démon pour
revenir retrouver own d'adam west view
ou second cas de figure
pietro est méphisto je sais que je force
avec méphisto mais la lecture de la
série n'est pas simple et la série quand
même force beaucoup avec méphisto donc
voilà je pense très sincèrement qu'il
est quelque part ce que je veux dire
avec cette idée c'est que pietro n'a
plus le même visage rwanda ne le
reconnaît pas ne retrouve plus son
accent ne partagent pas les mêmes
souvenirs que lui bref c'est un gros
fake et il est grand temps qu'ils se
fassent cansell surtout que comme je
disais dans son vocabulaire
il parle de l'enfer disney et marvel
studios nous tendent de grosses perches
et sans oublier que dans les comics
méphisto est intéressé par les enfants
du rwanda car ils représentent des
fragments de ce dernier soyons honnête
je ne pense vraiment pas que disney et
marvel studios et pris la décision
d'adapter cette histoire sont % tirés
des comics mais agyness parle du fait
d'être enceinte a world vision se rend
compte qu'il n'ya aucun enfant à west
view est là pour halloween
la ville en est rempli et dans une
discussion banale entre frères et soeurs
pietro ose parler des enfants comme ça
gilles peut-être dans une idée de
réadaptation des comics méphisto
pourrait être intéressé par les âmes
d'enfants en fait rwanda peut réécrire
la réalité avec west view elle a même
créé la vie là-bas mephisto est un démon
enquête dame
je pense que vous comprenez l'idée enfin
j'aimerais finir sur une pensée plus
générale depuis le début on nous caresse
dans le sens du poil
vraiment des références à gogo des
costumes des comics le quatrième mur qui
se brisent souvent je veux dire c'est
qu'on met les enfants parle face caméra
les costumes dans la cohérence comment
tu veux imaginer un costume comme ça
pour halloween sans justification c'est
comme si nous notre réalité était west
view on a exactement tout ce qu'on
voulait le retour du mc eu le retour de
vision l'arrivée du quicksilver des x
men qui en plus aux mêmes faire une
référence au chromosome x et y genre en
rapport avec le gène mutant etc
les enfants du rwanda qui respecte à
fond les comics tout ça c'est trop beau
et on le voit dans la mise en scène
quand on passe au point de vue extérieur
tour devient plus sombre
on est de nuit alors que dans west view
tout est lumineux joyeux et c'est le
retour du bâton va faire mal car on sait
que l'épisode 9 va nous ramener un gros
caméo est forcément une révélation pour
la suite des événements pour le moment
strange est le candidat idéal
néanmoins j'aimerais vous dire que
wendat ne sera pas forcément une
antagonistes
depuis toujours elle est présentée comme
une avant joyce et ce n'est pas en un
claquement de doigts qu'elle devient le
prochain vilain du mc ou non si strange
arrive c'est pour stopper la mascarade
révélé et véritable secret de west view
est la conséquence des actes de rwanda
je ne sais pas vous mais quand pietro
parle des enfants
on dirait que son discours est à double
tranchant et que les enfants ont été
réveillés pour west view comme s'il
était mort à la base comme vision ou
pietro après la révélation de west view
ce sera là où les choses sérieuses vont
comment c'est l'arrivée du multivers
suite aux dérèglements de la réalité
instauré par rwanda ou peut-être
méphisto un multivers que parcoureront
strange et rwanda pour trouver des
réponses et des solutions etc
mais tout ça ce sera l'objet d'une
prochaine vidéo
j'espère déjà que celle-ci vous aura plu
je trouve ça vraiment sympa d'échanger
avec vous sur cette série qui est si
particulière l'espace commentaires est
là pour ça je vous lis toujours et avec
un très grand plaisir bien évidemment
vous pouvez également rejoindre le
discorde pour les intéressés voilà on
est plusieurs à me parler de la série
one la vision sur ce dernier que ce soit
moi des abonnés et c'est tout ce qu'il
veut n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
pouce bleus à vous abonner à la chaîne
car ça m'encourage beaucoup dans mon
travail etc
et puis voilà écoutez que le lie à 9
soit avec vous c'était un argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]